Well hey guys what you got there kid no no
You find anything like with something wiki that's cuz wiki's are obsolete or jhana. What is this?
What?
The tesseract how can that be it's from another commission there's another dimension well
Then we should put it somewhere safe. No, I've got a better idea
three hell
In the hands of mortals the tesseract will only cause great harm, you must return it to us at once
I'm no mortal the tesseract is ours
So be it
And we fight, this is too easy bring it ya later
Kill Hitler after this one
Fools
Ketchum oh they're with me, buddy
See what do I do become pleasant but by this fight?
You gotta you gotta save the world
I already did
Nope
Hey, thanks for watching the video the guys from buff dudes and vsauce3 were awesome to work with and you should definitely check out their
Channels also this video is made possible by our patrons if you like our work
Consider supporting us on patreon and help us make even more epic videos